i'm song lauren
from new york originally
grew up in la also
and i'm the ceo and co-founder of squier
i'm dave salvon i'm from
brooklyn new york and rocklin county new
york i'm the co-founder and president of
the squire
you can think of us like the operating
system for the barbershop so we handle
everything from the booking
to the payment to the point of sale
system to payroll marketing everything
in between it's really meant to be a
full one-stop shop that does everything
that barbershops need to operate their
business
[Music]
it actually started out for my own
problems you know um back you know a
couple of years ago
it was a really terrible experience to
get a haircut um you had to call a
textured barber you have to sit in the
barbershop and wait you have to bring
cash all that can be solved by you know
technology and a couple years ago
uh ride sharing was all the rage and you
know you could book restaurants from the
phone so why couldn't you book an
appointment
and you know it was our problem but once
we really you know pulled black pull
back you know the the sheets on
everything um we realized the big
problem was on the owner operating side
they were using several different pieces
of software to solve something that we
thought
one software could do and that's kind of
what we you know did in develop squire
to solve all the needs of the barbershop
in one particular system
so we were actually friends uh before
starting squire we were both in new york
uh professionals i was in corporate law
and david's in finance and in business
school and we used to just hang out you
know dave thought his great house
parties in harlem we had a lot of mutual
friends and then we decided
we need to do
we needed a better use of our time
uh besides going out and having fun you
know why don't we develop something
that can last a generation
so we would just brainstorm ideas on the
weekend we both lived in harlem uptown
in manhattan so we would go to columbia
campus and actually just sneak into some
of the uh
the buildings and just whiteboard ideas
eventually uh that's when we came up the
idea for squire and like dave said it
was rooted in solving our own problem
something we both experienced you know i
started going to the barbershop around
six or seven as a kid with my dad and
this was 20 years later and the process
really hadn't changed and that's
something that we both realized and more
importantly we realized that no tech
companies in silicon valley were like
addressing the space it was totally
overlooked and underserved and then we
thought you know what there could be
something big here
you know it was very difficult to raise
capital in the early days the ugly truth
is you know um
we were targeting barbershops let's do
african-american guys
um they you know really
a lot of investors thought i'll jump to
the conclusion that we're only talking
african-american barbershops
but our understanding is everybody gets
a haircut um we had to show
traction we had to show that you know we
were targeting a broad audience and we
had to show momentum you know we started
company in 2015 and then it raised our
first institutional capital to 2019
so you know we were just grinding laying
tracks riding over them laying tracks
landing over to get to a point where we
had
validation
uh in the market
so our first product was a mobile app
and you know it took us a lot to get it
built you know we're not technical with
founders either one of us so we had to
find somebody to build it
and eventually we got that product out
to market we were super excited uh we
thought it was great uh we love to use
it but uh pretty quickly we found that
the market you know our customers barber
shops and barbers weren't really
responding well to it um they weren't
adopting it in the way that we thought
they would and that was kind of a slap
in the face or or a really watershed
moment for us because we realized this
although we were solving our problems we
weren't focused enough on our customers
and after all those months of hard work
we had to kind of go back to the drawing
board and say
how can we really build something that
fundamentally helps and drives value to
the people we're servicing which is the
barber shop owners and the barbers
so with that we kind of pivoted and
built a new product that was much more
focused on the shop operations um and
really handling all the back office and
most importantly the point of sale in in
the store and having everything fully
integrated and that was the product that
eventually really caught on and the
market responded really well too and
it's evolved into what we have today
we thought that you know we get every
barber shop in the world in two years
and you know we're doing 10 billion
dollars around revenue in the republic
but but you know i think you know that
was like
useful
optimism you know
it's beyond our wildest dreams you know
um you know creating a company with a
billion dollars of value
you know from where we come from you
know from our backgrounds
uh you know
i think
you know i was the wealthiest person in
my family before i started this and i
wasn't making that much money so now you
know to build something of immense value
it's just you know a different feeling
and
and sometimes i have to
i don't realize it until other people
say it you know i'm just like we're in
it and you know we're in the grind every
day and other people say oh okay yeah
it's something serious because you know
we haven't really changed
since we started we're the same people
you know we have a bet we have a little
more resources but
you hear from outside sources and you
just stop and say wow you know we built
something
yeah
i think that the approach we've taken
and the futures that we've launched and
provided really been kind of like the
the not only best in class but like
first in class a lot of times like we're
doing things that other companies
addressing barber shops or similar
industries like have never done um
adding this financial layer adding you
know financial services and you know we
provide supplies for the barbershop with
our product squire supply where they can
actually order their razors and neck
strips and everything right through our
system
we're going so deep into the vertical it
allows us to unlock value and provide
more value than you know i frankly i
think any other company does
we want squire to be eventually
they don't have to touch any other
system
at all you know they have to just turn
on the lights we'll cut here and
squire's gonna do the rest and we're
marching towards that
and i think we've done a great job so
far